tenemos varias figuras geométricas aquí
y probablemente ustedes reconocen estas
figuras tenemos aquí una figura similar
a la luna llena en el cielo y a esta
figura la llamamos círculo
así pues aquí tenemos un círculo
círculo que hace que esto sea un círculo
bueno cuando avancen más en matemáticas
verán cuál es la definición formal de
círculo pero una forma de pensar en ello
es que si este es el centro del círculo
y si vamos de un extremo del círculo al
otro pasando por el centro
esto siempre tendrá la misma longitud
esto tendrá la misma longitud que esto
de aquí
siempre y cuando pasemos por el centro
del círculo y bueno si esto es un
círculo que será esta figura de acá
pues va a ser un óvalo y de hecho todos
los círculos son óvalos pero no todos
los óvalos son círculos porque porque si
yo tengo aquí el centro del óvalo la
distancia de aquí acá pasando por el
centro va a ser más pequeña
que la distancia de aquí a acá también
pasando por el centro esto es mucho más
grande que esto otro y no corresponde a
nuestra definición de círculo entonces
esto de aquí no es un círculo esto de
aquí sí lo es y que hay de esta figura
de aquí que tiene tres lados un lado con
dos lados tres lados o también podríamos
decir que tiene tres esquinas un aquí
2 y 3
pues como tiene tres lados o tres
ángulos aquí en estas esquinas le
llamamos triángulo
triángulo
siempre que veamos una palabra que tiene
un tri como esto de acá es un indicador
del número 3 en este caso tenemos tres
lados o tres ángulos por eso es
triángulo ahora veamos estas figuras de
aquí que se ven bastante interesantes
cuántos lados tienen estas figuras de
aquí
vamos a ver cuántos lados
bueno esta figura púrpura tiene 1 2 3 4
lados
esta de aquí abajo tiene 1234
la figura de aquí arriba tiene 1 2 3 4 y
por supuesto la figura de aquí abajo
tiene 1 2 3 4
el nombre que le damos a cualquier
figura que tiene cuatro lados es
cuadrilátero cuadrilátero
cuando encontramos este cuadro nos
indica que vamos a trabajar con el
número 4 en este caso significa que
tenemos 4 lados y estos son casos
especiales de cuadriláteros incluso
podremos tener un cuadrilátero que se
viera así 1 2 3 4 lados y siempre que
tenga 4 lados va a ser un cuadrilátero
veamos cada una de estas figuras si
vemos estas esquinas de acá vemos que
podemos dibujar un cuadrado aquí en
ellas forman un ángulo recto o un ángulo
de 90 grados indicó en cada una de estas
esquinas un cuadrado
y si tengo en cada una de las esquinas
un cuadrado o un ángulo recto pues
tendremos un rectángulo un rectángulo
ángulos rectos en cada esquina por
ejemplo esta figura de aquí abajo no es
un rectángulo si yo tratara de poner un
cuadrado en la esquina pues no
coincidiría con los dos lados que forman
la esquina de la figura quedaría así o
podría quedar así de manera que no llega
a tocar ambos lados de esta figura no
como el cuadrado de aquí arriba que
stoke a ambos lados de la esquina
esta no es una esquina cuadrada y esta
tampoco lo es así que este no es un
rectángulo ya que todas las esquinas
deben poder albergar un cuadrado
esta figura de acá tampoco lo es aquí
trato de dibujar mi cuadrado y no queda
y eso es porque las esquinas no forman
ángulos rectos
así que este no es un rectángulo y este
tampoco lo es
pero qué tal este vamos a ver
si yo trato de dibujar un cuadrado en
cada esquina si lo puedo hacer ya que
cada esquina me forma un ángulo recto
este también es un rectángulo así que
estas dos figuras que estoy encerrando
aquí son rectángulos
tienen ángulos rectos en sus esquinas y
ustedes pueden darse cuenta de que esta
es una figura muy conocida es un caso
especial de rectángulo en el que no sólo
en sus cuatro esquinas caben cuadrados o
forman ángulos rectos sino que también
cada uno de sus lados son iguales miden
lo mismo aquí podemos ver que este lado
de aquí mide lo mismo que este lado y
que este lado y que este otro lado si
todos los lados miden lo mismo y todas
las esquinas forman ángulo recto vamos a
llamarlo cuadrado
cuadrado es un tipo especial de
rectángulo en este de aquí tenemos que
no todos los lados miden lo mismo en
este si todos los lados miden lo mismo y
qué pasa con esta figura de aquí abajo
pues parece que también todos sus lados
miden lo mismo este de aquí mide lo
mismo que este de aquí tenemos un lado
dos lados tres lados
y cuatro lados que miden lo mismo pero
los ángulos de sus esquinas no son
ángulos rectos
no puedo dibujar cuadrados en ellos si
yo trato de dibujar un cuadrado acá nada
más uno de sus lados se va a alinear con
el de la figura lo mismo pasa si lo
trato de dibujar aquí arriba no tengo
esquinas cuadradas como aquí o como acá
si todos los lados son iguales y es lo
único que sabemos con certeza vamos a
llamar a esta figura rombo y ustedes
pueden decirme a ver el cuadrado también
tiene cuatro lados iguales eso indica
que también es un rombo si en efecto el
cuadrado además de ser un rectángulo
también es un rombo
el cuadrado también es un rombo
veamos esta última figura este ultimo
cuadrilátero de acá lo interesante de
esto es que tiene dos de sus lados que
van en la misma dirección es decir
forman líneas paralelas estas dos líneas
de acá nunca se van a tocar por lo que
si tenemos un par de lados que forman
líneas paralelas a esto le vamos a
llamar trapezoide si tenemos una figura
que tiene dos lados paralelos le vamos a
llamar trapezoide trapezoide dense
cuenta que las líneas que forman estos
otros dos lados de aquí se van a cruzar
más o menos por acá
así pues esta figura de aquí se llama
trapezoide